hi my name is Megan Reardon I work for
the advanced research group here at
Wolfram research and today I'll be
talking about data management for
machine learning
data management or machine learning so
in this talk I'm going to you're going
to get a high-level view of the data
management solutions that were chosen
for our machine learning team here and
hear the rationale for such choices and
then I'm also going to give a quick tour
of the built-in Wolfram language
functionalities that will allow you to
easily interface with the external data
storage systems so currently we have
[ __ ] link external storage and AWS link
so the first kind of choice for data
storage is do you use a flat file system
to use a database system so flat file
system would be something like just
using your Documents folder to store
data there's a lot of issues with that
you're gonna have data probably in like
CSV files that's going to be a problem
also you know probably you would
organize that by data set but what
happens if you wanted to query by the
type of data that you have so if you
have images or if you have text or audio
or what happens if you want to search by
task type it's going to be really
difficult to do that if you use a flat
file system so most people use a
database system which is queryable so
that's going to help you with sorting
you know what kind of data that you want
also the largest data sets are not going
to fit into your computer's memory so
probably you would want to do a query to
limit which data you're going to select
so you'd have you know especially for
machine learning you're going to have
training data you're gonna have test
data and you're gonna have validation
data and you're going to be able be able
to want to be able to query based on
that so the next choice that we had was
do we use a traditional relational
database management system like SQL or
do you use a no SQL or a document store
kind of a system so we went with a no
SQL system one of the benefits is that
it's schema lists now that doesn't
exactly mean that there is no schema you
don't have to adhere to a schema but
you're going to want to organize data in
some sort of logical
you're not going to want to dump
everything into the same table or
collection and so what it does mean is
basically that the number of fields the
content and size of the document can
differ from one document to another so
for example this is I believe the image
net data set so if you notice here we
have two different documents and they
can have different fields in them so
this document does not have object data
so it doesn't have it doesn't have a
bounding box it doesn't have a class for
each of the items that are in the
bounding boxes and so the benefit of
this is basically you don't have to use
null values when you don't have a value
for that particular variable you can
just drop the variable entirely you can
still use null values if you'd like to
but it's not necessary there are
validation rules that you can use to
enforce a schema so if you want things
to be a certain data type or you want a
field to exist or not exist you can kind
of setup what you want it to be and then
if you try to insert documents into the
the collection it will reject them based
on the schema that you've set up the
document structure is also compatible
with that of a nested Association rule
from language so in MongoDB the it's
actually sort of a JSON style document
so it actually looks like this
whereas the same document in Mathematica
is going to look like this
so there is so yeah it's a document
oriented storage so it's stored in the
form of JSON style documents so this
image kind of shows you in a traditional
relational database management system
you would have your data normalized so
you would have you might split up the
data based on you know if you have city
and state and you might want to have
that in a different table than the
address and the issue with that is then
you have to join all the data back
together in order to have some sort of
logical document in a document store all
the data is already joined so you notice
here this is sort of a sub document of
this
so you can have multiple different cars
for the same document this makes it
easier for developers because they don't
need to actually join anything they can
just look at this everything is
completely logical they know exactly
what the structure is and you can nest
these as deeply as you want to so you
don't have to normalize it it's also
very easy to scale out so because of the
document structure you sometimes with a
relational database you realize that all
of a sudden you're gonna have to add
another table and then you're gonna have
to rearrange your entire thing and
that's gonna be a pain so you can just
very easily horizontally scale out from
this you can also do replica sets which
basically means you can have basically a
backup of each thing so you could do
three different sets and then if one
goes down automatically they'll they
call it like a they vote on which one is
going to be the primary and then the
primary gets added you can also do
sharding so rather than having three
sets that are the exactly the same you
can split your set so that you have one
piece one place one piece another place
another another piece so we specifically
there are a lot of different no SQL or
document store systems what we
specifically chose MongoDB because of
its popularity so you can see here in
all of the different document stores
that there are MongoDB is by far the
most popular one and it's actually if
you if you go to this website you can
view all of the different database
management systems and it's not far
behind things like Oracle and MySQL and
things like that so because it's popular
it also means that it's going to be
robust you got millions of users rather
than just a few so you know it's easy
it's easier to get help and it's easier
to make sure that the software is
working properly so that's where we
store all of our data for files you can
store files in a database file system
but we've chosen not to so one of the
reasons that we chose not to is that
it's it's more complex and you have to
sort of do more
planning whereas with things like with
AWS which stands for Amazon Web Services
and s3 stands for simple storage service
so with AWS you can store one file or
you can store a million files and you
don't have to change any of the
configuration you can just do what you
want with it also it's really helpful to
have an object storage system because
the size of all of our files combined
could be on the scale of tens of
terabytes and so it's very difficult to
fit all of that onto one single machine
and the individuals furring large
volumes of small files there's a link
here that you can read about it if
you're interested
but basically AWS has figured this out
and has done a lot of engineering into
making it so that you can quickly move
around a lot of small files or a lot of
large files and data transfer to ec2
which is elastic cloud compute is
especially fast and it's free and I'll
I'll get into that what that is in a
moment AWS is also geographically
distributed if you'd like and they
basically guarantee basically 99.9% that
your data will never get lost
also not specific to AWS but a thing
that we do in specific is for
duplication basically to avoid
duplication we name our files by a hash
of their contents so that we don't have
because sometimes basically there's a
lot of duplication across machine
learning data set so a lot of the same
images that are an image net or an MS
Coco and rather than having two copies
of those images you name it by the file
hash you'll always have a unique ID for
that and then for for training data
ingestion bench
marking whatever what-have-you we use
AWS ec2 which is elastic cloud Elastic
Compute cloud and basically when we were
considering this the the consideration
was do we use our own equipment or do we
just rent space whenever we need it on a
cloud service in the past we have tried
using our own equipment but there's a
couple reasons not to so training demand
can be highly variable around freeze
times we have a lot of developers that
are trying to train a lot of things
they're gonna need a lot of time and
it's and then there's other times when
we have no training so rather than let
machines that we own sit idle we just
rent space when we need it and this is
basically exactly the use case for ec2
we also we have like I said we have
multiple users and the configuration can
be difficult some users are going to
need one version of Mathematica some
need a different version it's hard to
tell what you're running at any given
time and you don't want to mess up other
people's trainings by changing the
configuration on them so if each user
can control their own machine they can
start it they can stop it whenever they
need it and they don't have to worry
that they're messing somebody else up
and also in terms of hardware trends
generally when you train neural networks
you're going to want to use a GPU which
is another reason to use ec2 GPUs can be
very expensive and they're rapidly
improving and so rather than buying an
expensive piece of hardware that is
going to then become obsolete pretty
quickly you can just pretty cheaply rent
space on or rent an instance on ec2 and
you know configure it however you want
with as big or as little of the GPU as
you want ok so next I'm going to show
you some of the built-in functionality
that we have created around these
choices so there's something in a level
on 11.3 and higher
called [ __ ] link that will interface
with a MongoDB instance so if you have
a MongoDB instance installed and running
on your machine you can connect directly
through Wolfram language rather than
having to use either you know their GUI
for it or use pymongo or something else
that interfaces with it you can use it
right from the Wolfram language so you
can see here basically we have a
connection function so we can do this
and you can you can hard code the
password if you'd like into the
connection or you can put in dollar sign
prompt and it will come up with a prompt
for you you can add it in and then
basically with this I'm just going to
show some of the very basic
functionality there's a lot of
functionality in here pretty much
anything that you could think of to do
with a database insert update delete
things like that queries so you can see
if we can get all of the databases that
are available to this user through this
clients that we just created so we have
our machine learning data and also I
should note that for our database we've
chosen to keep it behind our company
firewall so you wouldn't need to be on
VPN but obviously if you're using your
own instance you don't need to do that
you can also connect to a database so
once you see you know which databases
are available you can then connect to
the database and then use that to view
all of the different collections that
are within it a collection is akin to a
table it's the same same kind of thing
so basically we have a bunch of
different data sets we also have a
special collection called metadata so
rather than put all the metadata about
it so you know where it came from the
rights the the different data types
things like that rather than then
duplicate that across the entire
collection we just keep it in a separate
collection called metadata you can view
the metadata for any collection that
you've got so we can you know if we
wanted to we could view it for a
different collection as well and see you
know a bunch of information about it and
then you can use this to basically query
so if you wanted just image datasets
good query based on that or if you want
to just classification datasets you can
query based on that and then so if we
wanted to connect to one of these
collections this is the syntax for that
there is something in built-in that's
called the aggregation pipeline so this
is you can do a lot of different things
with this one of the you know very basic
things you can do is just get a random
sample but there's a lot of things that
you can do with it if you if you're
interested in reading more of the
documentation so this is the CFR ten
data set so it's just there's just ten
classes you can see we've got the the
file is named by a hash of its contents
and it's stored on s3 which we'll show
you in a moment how to actually get that
file that you want so this is just a
sample of that data there's also the one
place where we sort of we don't keep all
of the data in one collection is with
the file metadata so there's a certain
amount of data about the file so the
hash is the format you know whether it's
color whether it's black and white the
dimensions things like that it's a huge
amount of data so we actually keep it
separate and then you can join it back
together if you need to so then if you
were going to write a query for the you
know whatever script you're going to use
for training you can do it this way so
the syntax is basically mongrel
collection find you put in the
collection this is the query so we want
just training data and then there's also
something called a projection which
basically you can decide which variables
you do or do not want to see so if you
say false you won't see it if you say
true you will see it so that's probably
what you if you're going to want to
train with this data you're going to
want to get obviously the training data
and not the testing or validation data
and then this actually has changed sorry
about that
so we have something called external
storage which interfaces oh yeah
which interfaces with s3 specifically
its we may add other systems to it at in
the future but currently it's just for
s3 so it's a multi-threaded downloader
using the Amazon C++ SDK it will be
available in versions 12 and above it's
not going to work on the build you have
for the conference unfortunately but it
will work in the released version of 12
currently this is internal functionality
so there's no official documentation
available it is subject to change and
it's probably going to be exposed to be
a service connect in the future so in
order to use this first you would have
to get the pack lit you also have to
have an an AWS account and you have to
configure your credentials on the
machine that you're using so if you're
using your own machine you would do it
if you're using ec2 you're going to want
to configure on that machine as well and
then there's a link here if you're
interested in seeing how to do that so
for this basically you just do a very
simple s3 connect we've established a
connection and then we're going to go
back to our MongoDB data to get a couple
of to get the data that we want so we're
just going to get the training data here
it's just gonna take a second because
there's 20,000 files in here we're just
going to show us five files right now
rather than downloading all 20,000 so
here's the file names that we're going
to get and then all you do is s3
download tell it which bucket it's in so
buckets are a way of it's essentially a
folder on AWS s3 tell it the file names
that you want to use and it will
download them and then if you just do
import you can see the files I know
they're very they're very small and
they're very low resolution but yes so
you can get that and then you can use
these files to restructure your data in
whichever way that you'd like to do to
restructure your data
and then lastly I'm going to show you a
WS link which is available in versions
eleven point three and above but it's
also still currently internal
functionality so there is no official
documentation yet and it will be in it
is subject to change I should also point
out that through AWS link you can access
both ec2 and s3 right now probably the
s3 functionality is going to be taken
out and replaced with the external
storage functionality so again you're
gonna need an AWS account and you're
going to need your credentials
configured but you can just simply
connect to the ec2 client and there's a
lot of things that you can do in here
there's a lot of functionality in this
you can see what kind of images you have
which are basically it's a base
configuration that you would launch your
instance with you can see what kind of
security groups you are and again on AWS
you can configure certain security
groups so that for example you know you
can access different things depending
you know tighten up security depending
on what you want to do with it keep a
key pair is something that you're going
to need in order to access it basically
instead of providing a password when you
log into ec2 instances you have a key
pair so you have a secret key and a
public key and so you can see these are
all the different keys that we have in
our system currently you can also view
the names of available instance types so
these if you go to this link you can see
what these actually means so it's
basically like a configuration for a
certain amount of RAM certain amount of
CPUs GPUs whatever whatever type of
machine you want to rent this is how you
would figure out which one and you can
also do a lot of things with these you
know you can create an instance you can
delete an instance or creates images
security groups things like that and you
can
also launched an instance so normally
you would have to go oh I know sorry
normally you would have to go through
Amazon's website and go to the console
in order to launch a machine but we've
built something into the language so
that you can do it straight from ec2 I
mean from welcome language so you can
create an instance you just have to
provide it with the client the AI what
type of instance you want the key pair
that you're going to use and security
groups I believe is actually optional
there's a lot of other options for this
so for example if if you need to you can
attach a second hard disk which is
recommended if you need more than 200
terabytes of space because a root volume
won't configure properly I've tried this
before and it's bitten me so yeah root
volume will not configure properly it'll
only mount 200 terabytes of it and then
whatever else you won't be able to
access so if you need that you can
configure it so that you have an extra
hard drive you can also attach an I am I
am role or security groups both of which
are used to deal with permissions you
can also launch spot instances which are
essentially rather than paying a set
price for the instance you pay a lower
price and tell it it's kind of its kind
of like bidding on eBay you you tell it
how much you're willing to pay right now
how much you're willing to go up to and
if somebody else out bids you then you
get kicked off the machine so it's a
very risky thing to do if you're doing a
really long training you don't want to
do that but if you're just using it it's
a way to get basically cheaper machines
the other thing that you can set when
you're launching in an instance is the
region or the sub region that you'd like
to use which you can read more about so
we can actually launch an instance
straight from Wolfram language we can
then tag that instance so that everybody
knows it's my instance and they they
can't delete it and then we can get the
shell command that we would use to
actually so if I put
straight into a terminal window I can
just access the machine that I've just
created which I won't show at the moment
and then you can also terminate the
instance so you can shut it off straight
from the Wolfram language rather than
doing it to the website so putting this
all together basically if you wanted to
say train a neural network on on ec2
first you would determine what kind of
data that you want using [ __ ] link so
you'd probably on your local machine
figure out what queries you want figure
out what data you're going to use and
then you would create a script so you
would you would connect to [ __ ] link do
whatever query that you want to do then
download the accompanying files from s3
using sorry got to rename that again I
will repost this um this notebook with
the updated names and then depending on
what your going to want to do you might
want to restructure your data so you
might want to have it go straight from
the image to then what class that image
is and then you would train or do you
know you would you know set up your your
script so that you can train or do
whatever it is that you want it to do
then you would launch your ec2 instance
using AWS link copy your script onto the
instance and then just run the script
and and that's basically how you would
do it so we do have the the built-in
[Music]
Wolfram language documentation for a
[ __ ] link we unfortunately do not have
it at the moment for the external I
can't delete that at the moment but yes
so basically you would have to use the
question mark syntax for this which then
you could you could get
that's weird okay well that usually
works so this would basically instead of
a documentation page it would just show
right here in the bar what yeah I'm not
sure why that's not working but yeah
normally you would be able to see how to
actually use that that function and then
so this the same thing goes for the AWS
linked documentation and you can see
there's quite a bit of functionality in
there and then I also just added a
reference to the AWS documentation
they're their official documentation
[Applause]